[Music]
all right YouTube this is it all of you
all of you out there in the digital
universe have been waiting for this and
especially on the Twitter the anonymous
people and the furry cats and the green
frogs and the rest of you you've all
wanted this so I want to set a couple
things up before I mentioned and I say
hello to my guests today I'm sitting
between two people that I consider
friends two people that I respect two
people that were brave enough to not
just fight about things online and from
the comforts of anonymity but two people
who were willing to sit across from each
other with serious disagreements with
some some bad blood there and some
things being said already but we're
willing to come here and talk about
everything that we're going to talk
about for the next hour and to me that
already is a win for everything that's
going on in the country these days
everything that's going on online these
days and everything else beyond that the
three of us well you know what I'm gonna
do some intros for so of course you guys
know Candace Owens red pill black
Candice was a guest on this show just
about three weeks ago and I think that
was one of the things that kind of put
you on the map and then just literally
about four or five days later it seems
that this whole explosion about what
social autopsy is or and what it was
kind of happened anyway welcome back to
the Reuben report I didn't know was
going to happen that quickly
yeah yeah and to my right is Blair white
who is a friend of mine who has been on
the show a couple of times and third
time now you have entered that is a rare
Nick that is a ray I think we've a
couple four timers but you might be the
one three timer right we will definitely
go for four but you are an absolutely
outspoken and I think irreverent fighter
against so many of the forces that I'm
fighting against all the time and and
both of you I think are fearless
defenders of the things that you care
about just a couple of quick things I
think that the three of us sitting here
if I dare use a little of identity
politics against itself for a moment gay
trans black yeah
yeah a black conservative a trans woman
who really leans right if not I don't do
you call yourself a conservative yes
okay so okay so we've got a black
conservative a trans conservative a gay
liberal but I'm an old-school liberal
which is everything against identity
politics these days and I know none of
us care about that stuff per se but I
think it's important just to put it out
there that we're doing this and that
that didn't of itself is a little bit of
a statement right there and we're doing
this face to face and more portly than
anything else perhaps we all were
lefties yes we all were on the other
side of perhaps where we're at now
politically that's wildly different yeah
three years ago yeah that's not that
long ago you were wildly different 18
months ago 18 months ago and I've kind
of had a slow evolution over these last
couple years and I think all of those
things are worth saying because I think
actually that there's a lot that we do
agree on and hopefully we can get to
some of that but I know you guys are
watching because you want to find out
more about what actually happened with
Candace's website social autopsy now she
explained this fully to me when we sat
down about a month ago and then after
that a bunch of youtubers started making
videos about her comments on it was some
of it true it sounds like maybe some
definitions were slightly confused I
think I've talked enough what I thought
the best way to start would be for you
simply to just explain once again your
involvement in social autopsy and and
why you did it and sort of where it's at
at the moment and then we'll go from
there
right so I just want to start off
because we just had a conversation
off-camera she posted something that
said my predictions that I talked about
I'm not comfortable using the she
pronoun not because it's not anything to
be disrespectful it's just that a lot of
people that follow me don't know that
Blair is trans and a lot of people that
follow her maybe don't know me vice
versa and I think that it betrays the
audience when you make it sound like
this is a petty catfight and there are
two girls sitting across from a table
when in fact it is a grown man sitting
across from a grown woman who has had a
lot of things to say about me when I've
never even met you or said negative
comment about you so I just want that to
be very clear happy to for the rest of
this yeah it should be very clear both
adults you know
no no we're done we're definitely adults
I just think it's interesting how you
act like you're above the ad hominem is
you above attacking someone when in
reality you and I both know that the
situation is you're using those pronouns
and you're saying what you're saying
calling me a grown man that's the kid
attack the notepad and let me finish
that you're doing that in a way to be
passive aggressive and petty but in a
way that your audience doesn't actually
read because you do have the very
hardcore conservative audience and so
they're not really gonna read as petty
everyone else will I don't want them to
think that this is a catfight between
two girls it's not I'm saying that you
are no it's very important because it
really isn't though but we can but we
can move on because it really isn't
about oh shoot me and you care for a man
I'm happy to call you a shoot more the
rest that we can move on from the
pronoun thing but you have to start by
calling me man okay well I don't want to
have to afterwards say well if you are
this is your stance on trans why did you
sit across from a trans person and call
them cheese so I'm making it clear
because as we know you guys like to dig
up every single thing that I do in every
single meal I dug up everything you've
done out of everyone Candice there's
been a lot of youtubers that have come
out against you so I actually have a
question here before we go out of all
the youtubers so Doug stuff up about you
I never made a video I'm a youtuber if I
don't think some junk on a video I
jumped on a video for our stream of
which I was on for probably 15 minutes
now we're in 15 minute I would I was I
was not on a stream for an hour on for
an hour and 15 minutes until Barbara
came on the stream i watch all right so
you know let's do this let's just just
to clean this up so we don't I just want
to get to lost in the weeds of every
little word I think look you guys know
my feelings about free speech and where
I'm not gonna tell you what to say how
to refer to Blair and Blair can
obviously defend herself we can do all
that but just so we don't get too lost
in that stuff let's just try to stick to
the original story here I think it's
fine that you you promised it that way
you defended yourself I think that's
that's totally fine but we could end up
in the in the back part of this forever
so let's just get to the to the how did
this whole thing start okay so the
backstory to the backstory obviously you
know about social autopsy but there's a
very relevant part of this which is
essentially that when I was in high
school had experience it happened to me
and it's something that I like to talk
about factually and I hate talking about
it because it involves other people and
I'm out here talking about my opinions
my beliefs when you're involving other
people I think it's a little unfair when
I was a junior in high school I received
about
one night I was sitting on a couch my
boyfriend I receive anonymous phone
calls and at the end of watching
Talladega Nights with my boyfriend I
picked up the phone I listened to the
voicemails and they were people for boys
that were swimming back and forth
calling me a dirty [ __ ] saying really
talk either your family saying you're
we're gonna do to you like we did in
Martin Luther King put a bullet in the
back of your head made references to
Rosa Parks it was really probably the
nastiest thing that I've ever heard in
my entire life after hearing that and by
the way this is not a victim story it's
just something that factually happened
that you guys can all research after
hearing those voicemails I went to
school the next day and I didn't call
the cops or anything but I was a little
terrified because I didn't know I did
not know four people that wanted to see
me dead and that hated me period I went
school the next day the teacher
essentially was we were talking in a
philosophy class I brought up when it
happened it was like a moment where it
made sense to bring up what happened in
it before and the teacher jumped up and
said like you're gonna the principal
right now you're reporting this like
that's very serious like I want to take
you right now he picks me up go into the
principal's office and she hears the
voice mails which I still had there were
three of them and she made the decision
to call the police like totally I would
have never called the police or have
done tonight before it turns out by some
random stroke of like super misfortune
that one of the kids that was in the car
when they left these voicemails happened
to be the current governor of
Connecticut son and where this would
have normally been like maybe like a tap
on the finger sort of a thing that's
turned into an FBI investigation and you
know the then mayor was making comments
that were very like you know political
became political so all of a sudden I'm
I'm in school and I've got the
n-double-a-cp on the front steps I'm
very if you know anything about me I
hate the n-double-a-cp because of this I
think that they are a trash group and
that they literally extort black
people's emotions for pay which is
another thing Blair you don't know where
I send anything for you to call me a
fraudulent conservative you don't know
the things that I've lived through so
that was something that I didn't really
understand a lot of things I don't
understand to you so I'm I have a
million questions for you because
unfortunately you'd have me blocked up
until like two days ago right over one
tweet I sent to you so no it was a live
stream it was a live streaming on a live
stream for not 15 minutes I hope people
go and fact check back
there for that long that's the first
thing the second thing is again you had
me blocked before the livestream and we
locked before the livestream so and
you've had a million people block you
blocks right well I'm gonna get into
that he's gonna I want to find you I
think first you had it I'm just saying
I'm glad that we're actually having a
conversation because prior to this the
reason why it's actually gone to the
point where have to do on the rhythm of
work rather than just a quick exchange
on Twitter are you making a video on
your own channel it's cuz you've blocked
conversations I just want to be clear
you're allowed to tweet out your trash
and I am supposed to then defend myself
rather than you get on Timmy first for
answered your work you're absolutely not
supposed to you defend your life you
don't have to do anything right usually
your your might might your son say that
I blocked you after and they're insulted
me publicly to what do you have a
hundred and thirty thousand doesn't even
doesn't even make sense to you like
saying that right now Candice Candice
you have every right to block me there's
no you can not respond you can respond
you can block me whatever it is what I'm
saying is people are criticizing the way
that you pay on the situation you have
the backstory which our absolute let you
finish but the way you're dealing people
calling out the story and calling out
things that they think maybe are
fraudulent maybe they're not fraudulent
maybe you can clear that up is you
haven't actually cleared it up you've
blocked everyone people can attest that
everyone Andy wore ski Bungie King Dave
: who actually provided screenshots with
things he said to you so unlike me I can
see you blocking me for calling you
trash and honestly I'll say I'm sorry
for calling you trash that's totally
fine but as far as him he sent like four
or five very respectful tweets just
asking you for questions asking for your
started the story so if he made a video
I would just like to hold on they made
the videos and then ask questions I
don't do that I don't go she ate with
terrorists you know to make it look
Harry you're a lying okay issue and then
saying now you better come to me and
answer me
who does that anything hold on it's an
expression I don't negotiate Aires don't
take it to heart it's an expression not
taking it hard it's just kind of silly
all right an expression oh no we got it
we got to get the full story before
because otherwise there's gonna be
enough people watching this that still
aren't clear on the whole story
right that if we go too far into the
follow-up we're gonna get lost here by
the way I just really quick want to
mention that when you texted me and said
I want to do this on your show and I'd
like to do with Blair I thought about it
for a minute cuz I wasn't even sure if I
wanted to get involved in this I think
that this Twitter YouTube
ramaa I think causes it's partly we're
all here because of just this drama
machine that just endlessly drags
everybody but to to both of your credit
you asked me to do it and I texted you
and literally within 30 seconds you said
you would do it and there that's that's
that people should know that because
this is we live in a time when no one
backs themselves up they hide and say
all this crap so I just put that out
there but let but let's just let's just
get through the story and then we can
then we can do the rest long story short
this was categorized as a hate crime the
FBI was involved I was out of school for
about six weeks and just imagine like I
didn't even want to report it and then
having like what felt like your entire
life it was front page of Connecticut
newspapers for two months of people and
a lot of the stuff that you had to read
because remember the FBI was involved so
they wouldn't make any arrests they
wouldn't do anything as they wanted to
dot the i's and cross T's they're done
with a politician a democratic
politician right and he's not being
honest he could have easily just been
like my kid did something really stupid
he's trying to be a politician
essentially and when these arrests were
finally made a while the investigation
was going on people were just on the
internet just speculating just like and
not being aware that they were talking
about children you know they know I'm
saying I was probably the eldest I was
17 years old there's a youngest person
in that car I didn't know any of them by
the way this is like a drunk phone call
I knew one count of the four kids the
young is can that cause 14 years old so
these kids are getting called racist so
yes and I personally like I hate labels
like racism
I hate boom you call somebody a racist
sexist it really stings me because I
think it's wrong I think it's wrong that
a fourteen-year-old got labeled a racist
that I've got instead of being
reprimanded or told why it was wrong so
I'm very against Lee well another thing
that you know from my history have
always been very conservative on
following this event and I barely made
it to college because of this I mean it
was like something that was really
taxing that happened in my senior year
and following this event I developed
severe anorexia like it's a part of my
story or something that need to be sorry
about people have anorexia are just
looking for a way to control to control
mechanism so if I felt like my life was
completely out of control and people
were basically able to freely say
whatever they want about me and it was
permanently on the internet like this
situation that happened and the N double
AC P final politicians and nobody gave a
[ __ ]
about the kids that were involved in
this nobody cared about the kids are
involved in this
I developed anorexia the I think the
ringleader they kept calling him that
like had these kids call me hat went on
to have like DUIs he was like a closeted
gay at the time everybody's life got
ruined by this and it was something that
I never wanted and it ate me alive it
just was like this is it like the
Internet is forever and these things
happen you get to write about them and
you get to politicize something that's
not true right trumped when I got over
my anorexia I think I was in I was 22 at
the time was in 2012 like I had fully
honestly just I thought through it it
was one of those things that I had to
sit down a really question where did
Santa Rex come from what am i trying to
control and what have I learned from
this
I fought about children I thought to
myself like technology is something that
people don't talk about give a TED talk
on this which many people that have
staunch to defend they may have seen my
TED Talks they knew where my heart was
that when I did this I felt like kids we
are in like a different generation
you're also young as well so you have
you know we have Instagram Facebook they
never had this like you when you were in
school or not trying to like me you
didn't have this you didn't have and
there are 10 year olds that are killing
himself over snapchat and it's all like
just because the end of my dad when I
was growing up my dad had a beeper and
then all of a sudden we have Facebook
and Instagram all these things and I
thought to myself what a way if I can
come back and create something that
helps kids navigate technology right
without ruining their lives like this
kids need to be arrested for saying mean
things no I disagree with that
like I disagree even though they
characterize characterized me as the
victim and characterize these children
as the aggressors I felt that it was
wrong okay so you created social law
actually with the idea that it was sort
of gonna almost self police some of the
kids ability to ruin themselves right
exactly so what we thought was what if
there was a way when kids do these like
stupid things and we initially always
thought about kids we had to change it
because people said first try it on
adults try to send a little news service
people are sensitive when it comes to
children and we said what if there was a
way that we could archive what they say
with like a no no type of a punishment
like maybe it's held for for three
months and everybody like all of these
schools you were meeting with principals
of schools of high schools before we
even decided what we wanted to do to say
how can we
what would be helpful what our kids care
about well they care about being on the
football team right what if you've said
you're on you're on social type see all
these schools have this program you said
this to Carolina whatever it is now you
don't get trapped with 14 something
that's like petty you know but it's
better than getting arrested right it's
better than knowing that you you were a
part of someone's suicide because you
said something mean and because I don't
think kids have the mentality that their
brains are underdeveloped like our
brains were underdeveloped to really
understand the implications of what
they're doing yeah social autopsy was
born okay
the web developer that I was speaking to
and I was actually at the time remember
I used to work in finance I was talking
to some potential investors and they
said as I mentioned start with adults
start with adults do something like you
know build something that we can kind of
see what you're thinking of how it would
work in terms of archiving things and
we'll go from there
all right so to be clear and then I'm
gonna let you jump in when you created
this it was basically to defend some of
these kids from wrecking their lives and
schools would be able to look and maybe
go oh you actually did have a decent
track record here you said this stupid
thing but we're not gonna let that do
anything and it and unless I'm
understand what you know we have to do a
little sign here with definitions of
words because that what you're
describing there doesn't sound to me
like a dachshund daxing website would be
on Republic Lee I'm using this site to
release information about people it's
like but you're saying basically this
was going to be a an archive home for
schools to look at this information I
can sit through it okay
so I think calling it an archive I mean
it literally is an archive but it's also
a Daxing website anytime you public
people's personal information it is
personal information why not because it
was public because it was on Facebook if
that's still definition boxing if you
share someone else no it's not if you
share so it's not you can't change the
definition of God I think if you I
actually have the definition right here
if you share someone else's personal
information without their consent
it is doctoring especially when I
thought Google Docs is everyone actually
know I'll finish especially when it
comes to kids I mean she's definitely
playing the whole like warning protect
kids saying much I think honestly your
heart could have very well been in the
right place but the reality is when you
aggregate information of children and
you attach it to where they go to school
which was the intent of your website in
fact you actually said that it was the
best time to be on the website if you
were a chocolate teachers you can you
saw
it was the new side that it was the best
time to be on your website when you're a
child because it teaches them
responsibility of what they say online
right we said that in a video a single
child was on there but no I didn't say
that well yeah because we didn't want we
didn't want to shut off like if people
asked questions didn't want to show off
the possibility of having children if we
found out this work and this was
harmless and you know no harm no foul
we didn't want to come out and say we're
never gonna put a miner on here because
again the whole reason I thought of the
idea was because it would happen me when
I was a minor
well Julia legal to even put their
child's information on there there was
no children so this is like a no idea
messy conversation it's not a fans
conversation it was your intent so
that's what that's what you don't really
understand you think that because the
website didn't actually come to fruition
that people still don't have a right to
crest exactly whatever thing that's
that's exactly what you think but
regardless I made it very clear that
your intent was to put that information
on your website it actually violates the
children and children's Internet
Protection Act so it was illegal so
that's why your Kickstarter was actually
all right there were no children on it
you're talking about if there was I'm
saying you have the intact this is a
wild imagination you hack so you're
saying about your intent but just so
we're clear we're here because if this
was your intent and if it had happened
even though it didn't right Candace
that's why we're pissed and that's why
we're trying to ruin everything that you
are because we have decided that we're
losing one look of Woodham and should
have happened all right how am i trying
to rogue we're now we're dealing in if I
coulda woulda shoulda it didn't happen
here I mean it happened you're talking
about acts I wouldn't let me finish this
when you talk to bring up laws right now
that show it have been violated even
though it wasn't violated even though it
wasn't created because your intent is
what we were criticizing I intended
drive drunk I don't try me worse it just
makes we're not making sense because
you're did I do it yes or no maybe if I
could finish a sentence you would
understand that I am making sense but if
I can't actually reveal my point to you
how are you gonna dock this we need us
we need to stick with the definition of
Docs is that askew like I need to be
able to finish what I'm saying another
thing like I okay so are you telling me
that there it's absolutely insane and
it's absolutely Fantasyland for someone
like you to come out in your front a
staunch free speech supporter correct
you come out and you say I support free
speech that's something when did I say
that you I do but I'm asking what you
said you come in and you say Eddie that
was my whole [ __ ] I'm asking why did I
say that I didn't say it was your whole
jack I said that's part of who you are
and what you believe is that you are
some in support of free speech do you
think it's absolutely insane for someone
to question someone who supports free
speech
the ramen that I supply we finish my
question I have a lot of questions where
you have told me like actually ask them
right okay so you're someone supports
free sweets as part of your message as a
conservative which is a great message do
you really think it's that crazy for
people to see red cool black supporting
free speech and then look back a year
ago and see that she tried to create a
website that Doc's people and you can
say it wasn't oxy but when you publish
people's information we're gonna get the
bottom that is let's try to Plato
understand how it's perceived to be so
insane first fanuc see my two questions
here first it's important that we
address doxing and i'm gonna let you do
that yeah so let's just one thing at a
time I can there's a lot so first off we
can we can pull up your you're welcome
to pull up the definition not saying I
think part of what we're happy what's
happening here is we're struggling with
a couple so that as I said splash page
which you did forward me some emails you
guys were referring to this as a splash
is that now in essence in essence in
essence that may have been some
confusion by your web guy I mean I
forwarded me the whole change so I so in
calling it a splash page that's what her
web guy you know it wasn't a slash page
a splash page is literally defined as a
logo before you go into a web site you
add mold we were building a technology
you're not understanding this absolutely
no you're not and now you can let me
finish we were building a technology not
a website so what he was saying is this
is a splash this is a splash of what we
were actually never built it that's the
whole point you're missing when you're
building a technology okay so did you
have did you or did you not have a
database of 20,000 plus people that's
what you've stated there are two
statements you said there's a database
of 20,000 plus people and that it was a
non-functioning splash page one of those
statements can be true which one is true
what do you mean it was it was missing a
point yeah you're getting my last
patient not listening to that he's tell
you that he read the emails between me
and the web developers fantastic as well
I think what I think people are confused
by is regardless of the definition of
splash page if it was non-functioning
how did it did it in fact to collect the
information of 20,000 people wait it
didn't collect the information if people
are writing in the information it was
storing it was an archive okay okay hold
on so you all right
so just to bring our collective let's
just get about the technology okay so
you said there was a database and then
you decided with all it ever was was a
non-functioning splash me I didn't say I
literally called I didn't say that
you're not listening to me
let me finish it I did say them you're
not listening to me my web developer I
forwarded all the emails from February
did you not see these nor he called it a
non-functioning splash page because we
hadn't yet built the technology okay so
we're making its makeup a liar hold
that's what I wasn't okay with here's
everything that was told to me my wife
saw Barrett my web developer and I
really did database it's not a nun
functioning swashplate so are you
willing to take it back that it was a
non-functioning splash me I am more than
happy to admit like I said you didn't
let me say anyone have to go ahead and
gonna go let me finish my statement I am
more than happy to admit that when I
stated that I said that I we grated
verbatim and he saw the emails what my
web developer called it as soon as we
saw it he said because we're not
building technology if you don't have
the money to we had to raise money to
build the technology that was fully
funded okay hold on guys hang on sorry
it's that I think that's an important
distinction what we just got to there
you I am agreeing with you and I think
Blair will take my word for it that I
saw the emails that your web developer
to it as a non-functioning splash page
but you're also acknowledging that
that's not quite right and that's not
true okay but not true is that you're
making me seem like I'm a liar I was
never a liar I said what was told to me
from the very time that we started this
what my web developer called it from
start to finish I said exactly it was
told to me the issue is that you're
making it seem like I intentionally lied
to try to hide something that this is
you know got to call somebody a liar and
a liar and a plot ass [ __ ] which is
what you called me a thousand I can do a
fraud ass [ __ ] my pitch I told you
exactly what I know you love to pretend
you're both you at home and meanwhile on
your Twitter right now you called
YouTube which you're criticizing you
bottom feeders you called tree of
watching a crackhead you call they know
and you only think you call drugs okay
that's what I said I was releasing a
dokdo site in three weeks and she was
scared for her life that's definitely
not land that's a reality there's a bit
foul of a rumor to spread it's not
aborting a dog see hi in three weeks
hold on guys guys guys how are you can
you defend us what I said the cheese
we're not defending it all right
sympathizer that straight up seven I was
reaching a docking site in three weeks
that is that is the
ground zero this entire procurement that
she started not heard Spencer not
Richard Spencer like you said i
definition perpetuate you guys do don't
stop perpetuate this or no I said
perpetuate this you said the Richard
Spencer made a video on you I said if
you did it I said he'd let he made one
you said he made one when he did I said
perpetuate a video campaign about me
alright guys anyway my video on you and
he did it there's no evidence of that to
be honest for her your egos but I didn't
watch a single one of your videos except
for the Google hangout for the first
hour that you were on Candice I didn't
make a video in a video what's called
Blair she's such a mess this is gonna be
like honestly intellectually like it's
gonna have to go through i'll see such a
mess the fact that anyone believes her
is so sad she's a fraud she's a fraud
she's a fraud ass [ __ ] no these are not
hip-hop lyrics she's such a joke she's
so stupid this [ __ ] thinks she's going
to change everything and she's not
especially John going on Infowars which
is ridiculous the insult that she
launched towards Infowars because they
have a big audience and to them watching
my apologies I because I have a big
because let's keep it real where is she
gonna go after that some dumbass [ __ ]
don't believe her people that believed
me you're all dumb ass [ __ ] she's a
complete sjw people are so dumb by the
way this beef with her started before
she ever thought about daxing cuz she
literally says from the second I saw her
I thought wow that's separately an act
this is honestly it's ready
alright guys we got it you've got to
give me a chance to moderate this thing
otherwise we're just gonna be crossed up
over moderate okay
so it sounds like to me I'm just trying
to get to facts here cuz I get it we can
I can I want you we can do this all day
and you can you can look at every tweet
that we all said or that everyone sent
to each other and all the mean little
things and that's what everyone all the
people that that I think are the bad
actors in this and all the people that
just want us to realize asleep I want
there's nothing that's gonna make them
happier than to watch you two just
screaming each other so right so I am
going to try to get it to something a
little above that okay you made the site
you were you made what was referred to
in your documents as a non-functioning
splash page you are acknowledging that
it did take in information meaning that
people could submit information but it
was but it was Facebook pages
and things that matter you are not
denying absolutely not except that that
that the site that was was being
referred to as a non-functioning splash
page how did I had deed taken for
information we're not you were not
denying that not at all now as I
understand the definition of daxing but
this is I think where maybe we could get
a little a little lost in the exact
specifics is that daxing would only be
if that information was released right I
don't think daxing is taking in in for
me and it has to be personal information
so you're safe and addressing something
that you could stalk just to be clear
that all the site did was taken public
information public information that's
why they were late this is what was so
funny like watching this like ridiculous
stream with them is like he's like yeah
I know that these profiles are real
because I found people on Facebook derp
we found the people I'm public we didn't
even find them like we didn't search of
people's names it was like publicly on
Facebook like if you jump in on cnn's
wall by the way this was all for a test
this was all for a test so even though
it's taking those names these weren't
people that we were even going to have
on database period it was just a testing
phase so we could go out to investors
and get funded that was it okay to give
you a huge especially saying that it was
a testing phase yeah the problem is
those a lot of those people that were on
in your database were Doc's were
actually Doc's again what do you what do
you mean the interaction talks they say
yeah if you look at the Kiwi farms link
the people are spreading around there
are people posting in that thread
sharing their personal addresses and yes
that [ __ ] that was never I'm not
gonna argue that there was never a line
for that to be included on my website I
don't care what any farm because a dog
can eat oh listen they didn't get the
address from your website see if you
also get in dachshund when you create a
digital
basically hit list of online bullies
you're in you're enabling vigilantes to
go on to there and enact dachshund
wherever they wanted you if these people
these people's businesses were wondering
what Kiwi farms did this is crazy though
if I take a screenshot of their name and
you're doing it looks like it's not from
my website so hi know what something
like that
the point is when you create an online
digital hit list of online bullies this
was you this is done for this I'm sorry
this not done for this was address
someone got
except for it was last year the same
time everything has it here yeah because
and at door Zoe Quinn attacked us and
start a chance all right
now it's my family on kiwi farms okay
okay hang on a second so just to be
clear what you what you're showing us
and that's horrible
and that's why I don't care I'm serious
I think even that is being blind
fortunate nothing happened when
everybody's alive it was just like I you
know I know buddy it's been it's been 18
months nothing happened there were
pictures and names listen to me on your
website pictures and names your website
so she's admitting it's pictures and
names how the hell is that an app you
can google someone's net pages and it's
all done you're all my my point is the
intent Candice the point is when you're
in a digital hit list of people who are
online bullies especially when it comes
to you a lot of times it's conservatives
and people who are on this the reason
why these people are on there you can
see their comments that they made the
reason whether put on the website okay
but you vigilantes then go to this
website the point is that it was a trash
idea was an Orwellian night where people
went you an abuse they never learned it
I'm aware but the information Saturday's
the database was still accessible from
people that is the problem you never
officially launched it and thank God
never came to full fruition however that
information was still accessible
it was abused and these people were
ducks people's businesses home addresses
that she did she did make one
distinction there which is that it
wasn't your site and that's okay but
that was never my okay but I think it's
important that we at least get that out
so you're not levels angry I have a
question okay so my website had a
picture and a name and you said their
intentions were clear so if I go on
Facebook right now and I look under a
post under CNN okay and I see that a
person says something that I don't like
its public its public how is that I
didn't finish my goddamn question calm
down take a deep route you calm down I
am now there it's leave your comment
with you oh yeah okay Candice dam less
damage divorce we've been calling me a
fraud ass [ __ ] and all these names but
Natalie
defended by damn five but you're not
above it okay shreya cop how'd you talk
like generally carries on katakana today
honestly I actually think you're both
the button so what you're saying is that
people can find something ready followed
follow my train of thought people can
find something that they don't like and
they think that this person it's a hit
list okay what stopping the person from
just why do you have to go to social
socks you just go into Facebook and go
where we got it because if you look at
the comments from the people who
actually used your website to docs
people and again they Doc's them not if
you listen if you listen to people
commenting they're saying this is the
resource for using they went to you as a
resource to collect names and they dock
those people based on the mean comments
but they said online that's the reason
why they chose to hurt that [ __ ] look
remain comments that's what we did why
do you need a database you you can do
that the problem is this is making no
done it not understanding it no it's
like you're not understanding it's
already on Facebook or hey you're
obsessed looking at the first source
know when you create a digital hit list
of online bullies if you're calling it
digital hit list you're changing the
narrative here people who want to take
advantage of that will go to it and they
will Doc's people and it happened if
they really do that why are waiting for
us to work do you admit that people were
docked as a result no I've never said no
absolutely not I don't know I did really
really no only no one will talked as a
result of your website I have no idea
you didn't bring surf you're now asking
me what could have happened for all I
know you put this today I didn't put
everyone can go to Cuba farms and and
look out I'm sure you if you google
credo she's showing me something that's
not my web this is crazy you're exactly
what I was doc some people you tweet out
I gots people you're dancing you
literally said that that's not when you
said in your three use an ID optical
thing now what's that true thing one
that ensures a high dr. people wasn't
that true directly social autopsy did
not bother take it by get back that was
false take it back all right what did i
screen exactly she docks his people I
said no no I didn't I said are you I
said yes you did I directly yes you did
thing I directly tweeted to you so
you're proud of daxing people with a
question mark as in a question I was
prepared to clear it up
I Doc's people a thousand times and then
you clarified a couple of days on
Twitter when I when I asked you straight
up you said all I said was that you Docs
people all right you have been saying a
duck people don't bat chat it's cool to
be wrong IG says I just said I misused
the word shamash favors why can't you
say that you live Docs and just listen
if I misspoke and said that you directly
Docs people that's incorrect but I will
say right now just let's just listen
this listen you almost jump just listen
I will say your website was used as a
resource for doctors it was what do you
expect Candace when you create a website
that attaches people in there mean
comments to their employers their school
etc what do you think is actually going
to be the result of that people are
going to call to school people going to
call them let's pause the website okay
so with that question in mind it okay
first off I think she's using all right
it sounds to me if we could just try to
come for a second you are acknowledging
that no one dot that the site itself was
not daxing and let's add a list back the
lists we end in what you're saying is I
can't control what people do with that
list fair we got somewhere there okay
but it's like it's like saying you can't
control people do with the list but you
create listen that's like an you taking
a screen town of Chelsea Cameron I sing
I think about Republicans right and then
I'm holding on to my phone and someone
going people use that to dr. Chelsea so
you're at fault that's crazy that
literally doesn't mean there's a
complete didn't have it by the way is it
let's not get launched never long never
launched with the emperor it might as
well because the information was slow
and all those people were hurt as a
result of your website let's pause for
saying you acknowledge that this was
misguided now I've said it so that every
interview so I think that's a slight
that's an important piece here so I
don't think she's denying that another
site could have people he could have
grasped this information and then and
then done the daxing you're
acknowledging that her site did not do
that
thing and she's acknowledging that it
was misguided I've said that a thousand
times what's your line this is just a
witch-hunt you like already said that
all reason and then the thing is and I
don't I'm not comfortable for you
pretending that you did not put out
there all you guys said a thousand times
over with it I don't if I said that you
didn't know how people that was
incorrect I not a liar
okay but she's conceding the point there
she's agreeing that you did not Docs I
did not ducks anyone and and you realize
how harmful it is to take an error
something that was well intended I
realized very quickly which is why
Mike's running [ __ ] came to my defense
I met him when this was going on what
was that I laughed I laughed okay all
right if that's just honestly like it
should be beneath you but I guess it's
not that's why I met Mike Serna [ __ ]
right when this was going down I got
attacked and I realized that the reason
why I didn't want to launch his website
was because I literally realized that it
was going to be a tool for sjw's to
attack conservatives and we had nothing
to do with politics so when this girl
who she is
for some reason defending posted this
this original smear she said that I was
launching this website he was gonna turn
it against conservative you use their
money okay yeah and like the whole
reason I stopped the project was I
realized it was gonna be politicized and
it was gonna become a weapon that I
never intend okay okay I want to give
you I want to give you a chance to talk
on trying to drive through per segment
but do you believe her intentions there
cuz I think parties you know no one who
does bad things
acknowledge themselves as bad everyone
has good intentions no one does a bad
thing and really thinks before they do
at this but you believe that when she
had the realization that this was the
wrong thing that that's a genuine real
is it because obviously when she was
intending it of course it was intended
to be good thinking obably probably but
I really have like I know we're getting
stuck on the deaf nurse and I have so
many questions I want to ask because
I've been blocked for telling this
questions I want to ask so you stated on
your patreon tree of logic was paid to
why who do you have evidence of that
right no so mine or no I don't have
evidence if i 100% believe and by the
way you kept making it seem like I was
saying you were paid to lie or any of
the people that you hang out with
absolutely not I mean always
you called it a fund it has someone is
your next question we're gonna answer
yourself no I want you to finish
answering those words you didn't because
you cut me off while I'm loving you or
not what I was saying to was that the
highly suspect thing to me was Richard
Spencer Richard Spencer for a long time
this was not my theory or my conspiracy
has been considered to be a
pratik operated people have thought
these working for them because he
started on Wall Street like boycotting
on Wall Street as like a very liberal
person and all of a sudden he's the
leader of the white nationalist party
and every time he appears he seems to be
attacking Donald Trump trying to pretend
this is the brand of Donald Trump
so this one person who we were all over
was here why could me be a liberal in
the past why is that only illa for
disaster it does it doesn't matter I'm
time explaining [ __ ] this isn't
something that I started with Richard
Spencer this isn't my conspiracy theory
so for you trying a tinfoil and try to
essentially make it Gaslight me make it
seem like I was reaching the other side
you made the statement you tan to your
question to provide evidence that you
thought some people but you said it my
point is that so for Richard Spencer for
this video to be online this girl makes
a crazy insane video saying that I'm
going to launch this website in three
weeks amuse your conservative dollars
absolutely nuts it's a nut so you keep
saying I think she crazy I think she's
out of her goddamn mind I'm being 100%
honest with you okay
he retweets it in a matter of 24 hours
that just seemed like okay so before we
tweet but hold on I think there's
something there there is something
interesting to that because we all
discussed this before I discuss it both
of you separately beforehand that we
know sort of the rhythms of the internet
and how suddenly we've all been through
this right there's been times where
people were endlessly and relentlessly
and unfairly attacking you I've been
through in it you're through it now and
it goes in phases they see someone kind
of moving on up and then everyone jumps
on it right it does seem a little odd to
me but again I don't I can I always Carl
Sagan extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence so I can't but
it's but something seems odd to me that
why would Richard Spencer neighbors
retweet something he retweet it's just
weird okay Polly was able to get all the
way to Richard Spencer in 24 hours you
think that's weird you just either way
what you're thinking but guys the truth
is we're not going to know there's
nothing to tell
okay I'm a pretty short using all the
right sympathizer I have a problem with
saying we don't know the answer to that
because at the end of the day she made a
direct claim and she can't prove it so
saying we don't know the answer to and
it's kind of like giving credibility to
the fact that it might be a thing is
that you have all these notes but you
said you didn't even watch her video and
you are co-signing here to find my
cousin Billy Watson you're defending
Richard Spencer and a woman that
literally sounded like she was on crack
cocaine making up conspiracy about me
what she was in there coast language I
had to figure she was over upset by the
fact that I said something about
treating my screen made a whole video
about me you don't have what you did
it's a wonderfully alright sympathize
you to say that I'm asking you a
question
I'm asking you a question why are you
creative I'm asking you a question why
are you sitting here instead of saying
you know what her video was way out of
line and there were a lot of lies you're
not having any of the lives of in the
community that you perpetuate perpetuate
being the operative one day why aren't
sure everybody that's you do you want to
you can do okay like it's ridiculous
every chance Candice me be saying that
there's contradictory you know stuff
going on with you saying that ad hominem
is around how you win it's loaded it's
childish when you've called her a
crackhead that was me pointing that out
that was me saying that clearly and this
is where we can all find common ground
but we clearly have not all been the
best people you all use out homonyms you
refusing to answer Dave Cowens questions
and then saying that she's a crackhead
so she's not responding to you right
that's right that's that's you giving up
the deny genuinely think she sounded
like she was on drugs you can you can
genuinely believe that that's still not
sure that's what I'm saying that we're
none of us are above that okay you call
all the youtubers bottom feeders and
none of us are above that we genuinely
think that's why your answer to the
question why an answer is that anybody
that dedicates and especially in the
sphere of what's going on in the world
today right we've got like terrorist
attacks happening everything is gone up
a trump presidency the invasion that
just happened over in the Middle East in
terms of rushing the prints anybody that
dedicates five videos to talking about
me and something that never launched
like just a little weird to me just it's
like I better things to do than deal
with bottom-feeders that's I don't agree
with that we wish youtubers would make
better quality
receive these people and this is like at
no discredit to you I understand these
youtubers are your friends you were on a
video stream of me I was walking for an
hour and 15 minutes and Candice I did
not call me a fry and is saying that I
Docs people and saying that it was
generally what was gonna happen to
children because of what I did right
because you have the intention to think
they're wrong our children ever
intention you guys know around there
ever and is that not where you saw seven
no it's not that it could have been used
for bad things
that's what imagine if we lived in Cota
what it should all and all right okay
but just it's like oh my god okay that
being said you do acknowledge that by
collecting this information it is
possible that that information could
have got hacked into etcetera etcetera
even if I was not your it's actually
even possible it was it was people were
talking as a result of the information
you're here talking about the whole
situation is right I don't come I
haven't been sued if these people's
lives were completely ruined if it
happened a year ago Candace I don't know
didn't you see you I don't right now
alright but I think your work I think
you're both getting some points here and
it's hard to not get lost in the this
person said this on this video and we
tweeted this and that and I don't think
you you are admitting that this was more
than a splash page by the function
definitely what splash baby's okay you
are also admitting that your intent I
think you're accepting that her
intentions were not to Docs that her
intentions were good right when this
thing started or did we get that long
I think that as she is that it was
incredibly misguided I think that even
though yeah it was a third party that
went and used her information to talk
people that's what happened okay so
you're not denying that this is work
that people well they were docks by not
but not because of what you did
apologize for I would say I would argue
that they were docks because of what she
did because they used the hard way
baseball sent that you yes they cut out
but at the other day they didn't they
used your website as a resource this is
Christmas to me
little and you're saying what do you
mean the ancient website hold on this is
ma'am why don't you stop is on Facebook
ours just an archive
first all those people they found it cuz
it was on your website so just look at
the comments no no I don't know it's not
about admitting I think I've already
I've already consented to you okay I've
already conceded to you that they could
have okay absolutely gone on my website
and they could have found me superb they
did but they also could go on Facebook
and do that every single day so you're
making it seem like I'm special however
they couldn't have a double saying mean
things however figure out what their
names were the V reticular people that
were Doc's
we're on your website because of the
fact that they were on your website that
was from Facebook it was an archive what
was on Facebook do you understand we're
running in circles here we're going to
make sense we count so that means I know
Facebook is still a boxer's boxers okay
in your website so I so I as far as I
could tell okay what she's saying there
is true but you are acknowledging a that
wasn't the intention and that you were
misguided in Crete I mean it seems to me
that this whole thing I didn't
understand internet culture when I
created this at all III wasn't on
Twitter I wasn't I didn't understand
that there was this culture war going on
as I said I know you chuckled when I met
Mike sorry but she was incredibly
intelligent so I have nothing bad to say
about him he perceived that this was a
girl that was falling down the rabbit
hole had no idea how something that she
made would have been abused and that was
the end of it I mean intentions there
let's just try not to get into every
time yeah but the fact that she probably
didn't think it was this horrible thing
and it just ended up that way so one of
the things that's confusing me and I'll
let you go first on this one so one of
the things that's confusing me a little
bit is that nobody seemed to care about
this whole thing for about a year then
then your profile kind of got built up a
little bit and then literally within a
week of you doing of doing this show
suddenly everybody was saying this
animal because I'm a little confused
where did were people being doxxed like
what do we know when that when those
people grabbed them yeah that was
started acting yeah that was about a
year ago all those dachshunds I showed
you on the phone but the reason that
happened was because about a year ago
when the actual website was she was
working to make it come to fruition
there was youtubers Chris Regan and one
other person whether one other person
made of video made videos about the
situation
criticizing the website criticizing her
motives and she kind of I guess wasn't
on the radar for about a year until
after that she
back and she was about black new persona
and it took a few months people to
realize oh that was that person we were
all talking about a year ago that's what
happened so I think the idea that this
is all like some grand conspiracy theory
and that tree of logic was paid Richard
Spencer was paid it doesn't make any
sense it's this is relevant now because
these are biography and youtubers that
saw someone rise up quickly this is Envy
dress up his righteousness period this
does he make sense
Oh later it took them a while to click I
talked about it extensively every
interview I do I talk about gamergate I
talk about the red pill I talk about
social autopsy so this is all BS as I
said this is right this is Envy dressed
up as righteousness okay it took a full
a year later it never launched all of
sudden you're digging into people's past
and you didn't have the decency I
would've had a lot of respect for you
blaring why if you if you reached out
you we have someone in common if I did
know I did know I did one directly
tweeted you I said do you wanna do a
livestream and talk about it and you
blocked me no no maybe you did you see
after you called me trash I never saw a
tweet from you that said you want okay
well I did I did but um I returned right
well we can almost they all jumped up
and it was a dogpiling okay if eleven
youtubers are on the same livestream
that's a dogpile
you can't even a stockpile 11 youtuber
talking about one youtuber only you I
think both of you guys are above sort of
just the general I never dropped I've
never jumped on it no cuz I I genuinely
that's not the intellectual circle I'm
trying to run I would never ever ever
have jumped onto a livestream with 11
youtubers talk about you ever okay when
I was in when I was on those two okay
pause for a second just to clarify one
thing
one person did check on the on the
amount of minutes that Blair was on the
livestream it was approximately 40
minutes she joined it about 30 and left
around 110 I don't think is a long time
it they're talking about someone
certainly on an hour and you said about
an hour and half I said an hour and 15
min okay and I said about 20 minutes oh
we were both wrong about that alright
fair enough and I don't think those are
the things that are particularly for
here I don't think it is you're talking
about something that's the entire time
honestly Candice you know I'm not here
to hold you to your past we all have a
past we all were different we're all
different places politically a year ago
I'm sure we all work okay
it's not about holding you get past
everyone
it's about honestly the entire thing
again out of all those youtubers and
please don't interrupt me out all those
youtubers I didn't make a video yes I
was live for a little while talking to
people I did not make a video if
something if I'm a youtuber if I don't
make a video it's really not that
important for you to make a video that's
the first thing so I was never like a
bat invested in this which is why I was
kind of confused when she shows me the
debate we was gonna million youtubers
who have made like I said videos and
have like even if the facts are wrong
have laid out like fact this is why we
disagreed Candice whatever so again I
guess I would ask like why you picked me
and cuz okay I don't want this to go to
personal there's two reasons a I thought
that the irony like a dramatic iron
situation was irresistible like I'm
sitting across from a trans person who
would like to be called she and we've
accepted your transition from male to
female in your gender could you with any
tonight
give her give her secretary sitting
across from you okay uh-huh
who could not accept my transition from
liberal to conservative that is like
irresistible EW Roenick a beach because
I felt that the rest of those people
were bottom feeders looking for hits
okay and you have an audience so if
anything for you to show up today you
have everything to lose up and again
you're not gonna gain anything off with
me these other people who are at the
bottom demanding that I go on their
shows but coming against look at their
their YouTube pages it's like averaging
four thousand views four thousand you
solve something they're at a hundred
thousand views I knew exactly what it's
about
honestly can I borrow my heart I really
don't think this was ever about you guys
being concerned about daxing cuz the
information was right there as you said
my website never docked a single person
here I think this was always about
youtubers seeing someone rise even in
the in the stream which you were there
with that guy he says yeah no I don't
even believe it how did she get to this
many how many gets dismay subscribers
they're even talking about the way I
look all of these things it was never
about dachshund people it was honestly
too Nev jealousy right okay ever say
either of those things by the way just
you don't watching I never said anything
about your looks I never said no I'm
clearing up people watching you were
talking to the person that was saying
this I never I'm cleaning that up but so
honestly if my whole thing with this has
just been finding honestly amusement in
the amount of lives you told as a result
of people calling you up that's been it
how do I lie I guess you mentioned you
mentioned but you said
already that I was told something
different like I'll tell you what effect
so you're like you lied first of all and
said that it was Richard Spencer who
made a video you know I said perpetuated
you said made I said perpetuate it's not
retention said it in a video if you go
to I believe was your facebook video you
might post it on Facebook but if people
can't find it there and you were she did
a response to it
you said verbatim he made a video so he
didn't do that that's that's one line
okay the other lie and you already said
you can't provide evidence is that
Treaty of logic was paying I find 100
percent think that she's paid there was
no way my better by the way do you not
think it's a little ironic as you're
sitting here telling me that I was shady
for blocking people that this girl jumps
up and makes a video about me and then
blocks me you guys oh I'm at the dog
park this is why it's about Envy this is
this is why I notice about and Venus
baby talk about me okay for blocking
them meanwhile the person that started
all this blocks me so this is the part
of it look this is a part of the guys
right I wouldn't have done this if I
didn't think you guys were above this so
I think we got to figure out a way to
get out of out of the weeds on that
because look we can argue about whether
it's right to block people we can argue
about whether they just want clicks off
you which you do battery she really
tried hard to avoid answering this
question that I asked her who paid tree
of logic who paid Richard Spencer to
retweet something if I say that I think
something is paid that is that is that
my discretion I can't say I can't I
cannot present you a fact and you can't
present to me now that fact okay so you
made the bold horrible I'm smelling and
you're saying it's not true you saying
it's not you could be a look at whether
well you can't provide not you and I
can't prove it's true that you only made
the claim you speculated so it's it's so
it's all very weird that Richard Spencer
jump into this so early and that this
person made this video which was a
complete lie saying that and by the way
you're not talking about any of the lies
you told my video it's a mini to
McKenna's there's so held baggage we've
been saying I'm a liar but you're not
talking about evil I she take this
Candice first of all you think coming
off the dock Robo me first of all Canada
no first of all Canada slam it is
completely on you if you make a claim
about someone especially something that
someone was paid under the table to make
a video about you it is completely on
you to provide evidence for that okay I
think that's fair you are admitting
yours you are speculating on
evidence okay I think that's a fair
point I think she's admitting she's
speculating night so the the burden of
proof is on you it's not on earth to
Peter the other way I think that I think
that's fair I think we're basically all
agree yeah so so far it's like you
called Eric Rockhead you've said that
she was paid by someone it's like these
are just lies and you can save the
Europe but she told about your I am
youtubers are all are really the
gatekeepers of truth why are they
assessing the lies that this woman told
she saw a same site in three weeks she
says she does think that's true she
spent time 40 minutes to be precise
talking about all of my untruths
cherry-picking every single thing that I
have sent about the here so focused on
her seen her since but you're defending
your office we can't we cannot not talk
about it all you're gonna do is sit here
after viewing all you're gonna do is sit
here and defend this person then we're
going to talk about that man's nuts told
lie after lie after lie after lie after
lie but you don't care bout any of those
lies because I'm tell you what because
I'm new yeah this is env2 this is huge
ice it was dramas we're Candice it's
very easy to say oh it's because they're
jealous of you when in reality it's much
less about tree of logic and what she
did or done did not say I can I didn't
watch the full video I'm sure she did
say things that are incorrect that is
mean some of it wasn't correct it's much
more about the fact that you're willing
to tell lies about people in the wake of
this marketing you saying that she would
you hands the irony is once I finish
shake out a lighting you coulda lied to
both of you it's got to be liars both
you guys finish the fact that you said
she was Pam I didn't I make a video
about her
just let her pin no you just post it to
your patreon supporters that she was
paid to make a video about why it wasn't
I think it wasn't why do you feel the
need to always point out in videos on
streams I should say on a stream on a
phone call via right now sitting down
and your focus has been meat why aren't
you cuz you're sitting here making the
nose initially when you hopped and you
said she dogs people when you hopped and
you jumped on this phone and called me a
liar why are you talking about her life
it is okay let's go back to the why of
shame in the live stream if you watched
it you might have seen me say I don't
know tree of water I don't know if she
likes my content because I have never
actually watched her prayers I'm asking
a question why was it about me if your
whole if you're saying that all you care
about again is the truth Candice you're
the top because it video let the liar me
guys guys you guys pause alright here
listen we could do this all day I mean
literally we could be here for the next
20 hours doing this right so I think we
actually have made a little bit of
headway here believe it or not because I
think we've acknowledged that you did
not that when you realize the error of
your mistake I think you are conceding
that point but you're also saying that
that that being said bad things were
done with the information you're saying
you had no control of that information
and you I think you feel bad that that
actually did happen but this is the only
use oh wait what she never said she felt
bad about you woah okay so I don't I
don't want to put words in your mouth do
you feel bad that if a year ago peoples
were addresses you said it was a year
ago
like mitigate make it sound like it was
it was like a year well I think I think
partly what I'm really trying not to pay
attention to the nonsense on Twitter but
I think what certain people were angry
guy saw a certain level of anger with
you that you weren't that you showed no
remorse even if it wasn't your intention
right to do this and we're misguided
because a and we go back to she's
already can see the point so I'm not
trying to be a dead horse here she was
telling people that I Doc's people and
that was a lie so I showed no remorse
because they were accusing me of being a
doctor and that is a very strong word
okay and the source of that lies as
we've already talked about was not you
okay it was a video that aside from
saying I Doc's people said that I was
like an undercover liberal that was
using people for their money those are
really nasty lies though they're nasty
lies and rather than try to like build a
bridge which I recommend by the way any
youtubers that want hits like I would
have gone on and spoken about this if
anybody I approach like an individual as
opposed to like trashing me and then
saying defend yourself it was really he
I didn't know he made a video about me I
don't think he did but he definitely
reach out to you anyway he did but you
do make a video I just Lee I did when I
think except for some black I reached
out to you and I see any where she never
he made videos about me and then
basically I come on Elijah I'm not doing
her guys feeding mentality and then
expect them to defend themselves that's
not right I see people plenty of people
that make bad bad videos about me and I
could spend the rest of my life
defending myself oh I didn't doxy okay
so I showed
Morse because you made an accusation
that wasn't true and I understand what
you're saying about potential but if you
guys had always said do you understand
the potential I've said that extensively
in every single interview that it was
misguided that I can't like I'm sure I
can't stress that enough it's the reason
why I became Redfoo I realized the evils
of the internet what people were doing
to conservatives okay do you accept that
that basic premise is true that because
I saw a lot of times as well well that
likes no no I know you I know you can
see that but I seen a lot of people say
well now she's faking this whole
conservative thing and you know I said
that I had you on my show and we spend
about eight hours together after and I I
don't feel that and if you're doing it
as I said you right before we try to
you're a freaking hell of a job because
I think I'm a pretty good your second
character here's the thing I definitely
because again we've all had evolutions
so why can't you it is the irony of you
know we set up and we do these schwanz
videos to liberals and social justice
warriors and a lot of them haven't done
anything nearly as bad as creating a
website that attaches peoples mean words
to their employers in their schools so
for that reason I was never really prone
or excited about giving you so much
slack that I would believe that you were
genuine I was speculating like this was
just a year ago and now she's up here
being a complete 180 it's possible but
it was definitely you know a speculation
and again again I'm not gonna hold you
your past it's simply about the logic
hold like in the past month defending
yourself that I'm more interested in
directly so that's but that's that's
complete that is your to be honest
you're lying right now because because
your exact words were that you didn't
like me from the first time you saw me
this is before no I know I did I don't
think I don't like you because you're
very exact words I definitely said
anyone I I'll just tell you what I said
it's fine if it was wrong you can tell
me I was wrong I definitely said that I
think I think saw one of your videos pop
up on Facebook like a few months before
this entire thing happened and that I
read it I was like someone reading a
script I didn't particularly like you
yeah I said me to be a fraud instantly
so for you to say that this is like I
don't make it so we should not make this
about so I said you had issues with me
before this every but I don't think
anyone I don't think anyone watching
this is watching going the point of this
whole thing is is that Blair doesn't
like Candice or Canada to me it's very
high school nasty when someone says I
just saw you I didn't like you to me it
seems and I'm gonna be honest it seems
like these they're very high school like
these youtubers are very high school and
they see a new person it's about
taking someone down if you genuinely
hippier if you're genuinely a person
that cares about this movement that
we're all a part of different you know
definitely different sides of the
spectrum I don't think that I could ever
do some of the things that you did in
terms of talking about people for no
reason I've never even met
but affectionately what your interest
was your interests in helping why not
build bridges like why not like reach
out and say Dave like the respective
people Dave as soon as these rumors came
out reached out to me Paul Joseph Watson
who you hammered on this stream you
talked so much trash but Infowars knows
people that's a whole audience people
that you're just if you're part about it
this movement why are you talking about
like there absolutely no three later
answered Candace why are you taking on a
stinking it's not about taking you down
the reason I criticize POTUS with Watson
was because initially he came out or
what the response saying that your
website was from four years ago and it
just wasn't that would have some respect
you know him he gave us but he gave you
a platform all you had to do if I've I
saw something about Dave that I wasn't
sure if it was like the way that Dave
reach out to me the way that Paul
reached out to me but if these people
reached out and asked a question first
that's just being respectful this is
we're all participating in it why are
you trying to break it off by like
talking trash about Paul Julian you're
having trash about Canada problem you're
very like tribalistic and you definitely
Bank on this whole like groupthink thing
you saved yourself that when we hear
something about one everyone it's very
important to never become skeptics and
to double down back to me is a very when
did I say it double down you said in
your facebook video people can go back
you said it's important to double down
Sabourin should not become skeptics you
said that yeah oh yeah double on your
what I meant by that and let me clarify
is that one of the most beautiful things
about this is that that what I enjoy
about this conservative movement is that
it's a human to human experience again
like it's not believing salacious
headlines to being like we in a second
let me trust my gut I know I met this
person like you said I said Candice is
definitely not a fake conservative even
though this is what people are trying to
tell me I didn't proceed that that was
cool I'm not saying that if by the way
you do your research and you find out
that this person is a father you don't
go hard but grid up the courtesy of
respect but try it before you try to
break off this movement and basically
Gaslight people that watch about this is
a movement I mean I feel like here is
you've got you're part of them you think
by me criticizing you I I do but you
think my me criticizing you and breaking
off you criticized Paul Joseph Watson
Alex Jones in forewarned and media sites
were told that's fine
right that's what I'm saying I think not
being up there's nasty guys back there
were before I'm back I think there would
be no such thing as journalistic
integrity if everyone in this world had
this mentality of this person sports the
same president as me this first has
similar ideas to me I will never be
journalists I will never become a
skeptic we started John for them
research people that's what I'm saying
to you I actually both the green on this
but just last week I reached out you
reach out after you call the crashes and
idot's people Candice already reproduce
halation guys this is the low level part
of this that gets us nowhere right it
gets us nowhere
I'm trying to say something positive I'm
saying that I think that you could
apparent yourself better if you
genuinely thought okay this person was a
fraud and this is the distance so this
is why and in listen where we go from
here doesn't really matter because I
think that you and I are just
fundamentally different people and I
have the courtesy and respect but if
somebody once gave me a platform I
perceived them to be a good person
before I go on a podcast with a bunch of
people and they would have a good person
I'm not we had never met you I'm talking
about you jumping on talking about
Infowars who gave you a platform jumping
on a podcast talking about Paul Joseph
Watson Alex Jones I thought it would
made you a really crappy person so
because it was a cry for a house I've
did a wife she imparted Watson that
means I could never criticize him it's
all about Chris it's the way you did it
if you thought that he wrote something
that was untrue can't reach out and say
you could mount popa saying actually
I've reached out to him and he told me
this you could have pigeons facts but it
said here it is see routinely what
happened was it's drama drama
do you want help what happened was
public I read his tweets I didn't feel
like I had to reach out to me Kendall
clarified he spent the entire Twitter
for you trying to clarify what he said I
am mister do exactly what he was saying
I wonder why she might criticize him I
don't owe him not knowing it was that
her second tax you're saying is
disrespectful
don't ever talk to her I'm saying it's
harmful to them you guys guys I'm trying
to be respectful of both of you but we
gotta we gotta pull this into something
that makes a little sense here yes you
can say one thing and then I gotta get
this part of Watson Alex Jones any
amount of extra slack any amount of an
unwillingness to criticize them because
I've done a livestream with one of them
before
research research is an extra slack it's
what you should really consider yourself
a journal Candice research not
research and actually you think he was
giving me extra slack when he asked me
whether Doc's from here their true
intelligence candidates actually did do
the research kept hunters opossums
Europe Center website within four years
and you also live Islamic working for a
large another lie you told you said I
heard that she's I would never live
that's a lot I said I heard that you
were that's what that's I said I heard
it but I can't that is a complete
speculation saying I heard she's working
for import that's up and you said that's
why Paul you you lied on him I lied on
me you you grunt when you hear my
college why are you a part I was that
Ohayou appears welcome to your for me
say I want to hear it what MOOC a new
partner coming out let me say I'm saying
I said I heard she's working for him for
worse so it makes sense that Paul is
defending her does that make sense
that's the speculation what you did tree
of logic saying she was paid was a
direct claim that was not a speculation
there's a difference okay but whenever
debates when you're I'm gonna say that
you can speculate both speculative pause
pause guys pause pause pause please
please
okay you both speculate in different
ways no one's perfect here and and I
think you did make a good point earlier
that we've all acted in ways online we
don't all act with all the consistency
that we all say we want to and all those
things and okay none of the all the
drama stuff is where we're getting lost
I think if we try to get out of this in
any kind of way that makes some sense if
you if you basically believe her
intentions and her you believe her okay
we got the intentions part but the
political evolution do you think her
political evolution that's a lot of
people seem to be hung up on that do you
believe that to be genuine I don't know
my initial judgment based on her
behavior and the things she was saying
was that there was probably some amount
of like you know reading off the script
and saying things that people want to
hear that's to me that's not important
that's okay and I'm sure people have
said that about you and I'm sure they've
said it about me so so and I'm free to
say that my problem is when you make
direct claims about people being paid to
make videos she's ever long it's no
clear goals we can't go back to they're
saying I'm defending it when in reality
you are it's no no it's more about a
video I'm more like you know I didn't
can after you about on you about I do it
on tree object it's not about her it's
about your statements and the way that
you've acted in reacting to everyone
calling you out its
that you told a million lines realized
that this was a deep one your life so
you told her okay okay saying that it
was a deep up conspiracy when the
reality you know you even admit I oh
it's a deep web conspiracy you said you
saw the deep web conspiracy was what
this was when in reality you've actually
admitted during this interview that it
originated the web I can say to mention
or Kiwi farms pretty deep web that I
mean I will not hold on but you keep me
first of all talk to you web second of
all you admitted in the stream that this
whole thing originated Pro tree of logic
so is YouTube the Deep Web do you not
really irony of you defending the person
that originally drew beside sending her
I'm Fusco it's important because you're
calling me yeah I'm focusing on you're
trying to pretend that you're righteous
on your every heard its me was an act of
righteousness no no I clapping that
where you got your information
fundamentally a lot choice on your my
name is not tree I mean it sorry I
focused thing on your words I'm not
focusing on her it's the fact that you
said it's a deep well conspiracy however
you also stand that it originated from
her YouTube is not the Deep Web so it to
me it's okay to me more than anything
I've just found but you're saying people
pronounce I'm friend beaver arms that's
a deep web who was looking at key we can
determine both agreed that it originated
this entire controversy people calling
you out originated from tree of logic
right right the first video by the same
you said you got a we farms which is
that Deep Web Candice no Kenneth you
stated that this entire controversy
people calling you out was a deep web
conspiracy that's what you said on your
facebook video people can go back to it
right that's why when I'm salary you're
sitting across from me saying that it
originated from tree of logic who is a
youtuber YouTube is not the Deep Web
so my point about that is I've found
humor and the amount of deflections that
she's done trying to make it seem like
it's so crazy that it's a deep web
conspiracy and people were paid and it's
this huge conspiracy against her because
that makes people less likely to believe
it occasionally done that
now we're looking at take somebody down
tell you this I'm going nowhere so if
you don't like my face if you guys don't
like the way I talk if you've got my
videos I don't like my videos at me
you're gonna have to stomach it well I
advise you to meet guys I need you both
to grant me the respect of having you in
here to try to get some sense out of
this thing I get it I get it we're raw
here I get it but you got to do it okay
we can either do two there's two things
happening here one is the facts of what
happened that caused this whole thing to
happen right what are the facts and then
what is everything else of all the
behavior that everyone has done and
whether you speculated or you've
misspoke on this or whatever but I don't
think I actually don't think that if
there's any adults listening to this and
not just the people that want us to hate
each other I don't think they care about
any of that stuff that's my particular
opinion I'll let you respond to that and
then just pause for a second do you
think that's fair like I just think
there's two things on here there's the
fact of what Candis is and what she has
done and and if we can get to a truth
about what social autopsy was and then
there's just the rest of it that as you
said and I give you credit for sitting
here because you weren't one of the
people that felt that this was something
that had you had to make videos and on
all that so you're sort of you're sort
of hereby by proxy in an odd way but you
had the you had the you know the desire
to do it I mean not the desire I just
knew that like if I had said like I
don't really care about this it would be
candidates tweeting that I ran I knew
that okay so I didn't do that but I will
say again what I've cared the most about
and when I say care it's like I found
humor in it so I haven't cared that much
it's been me looking at the way that
you've lied and you've deflected and the
things that you've completely made up
out of thin air but has been humorous to
me that I have talked about but that's
what she lied she's okay she's alright
guys I guess the biggest part of this
piece the biggest thing to me is talk
about the biggest thing to you the
biggest thing to me is that the entire
thing was predicated on a lie which you
helped perpetuate to 130,000 people that
I Doc's people you've already conceded
the point that I don't talks people
you're saying that what you made was
used to Doc's people on a website that
you have nothing to do with okay that
was my thing that pissed me the most off
and you're already making that's not
true so you're you're more concerned
with how I responded to the lie that it
was about the show about me
yeah but you completely like separate
separate that's what I'm trying I have
time you say you keep pretending that
this is about me lined with the biggest
lie the reason we're here right is
because there was a clan that caught
fire that I personally ducks people and
that affects my integrity okay people
were talking about that vignette that
was actually valid people were tweeting
at the sound of light to you people that
I work with and people everyone reached
out because again those people are more
professionally they have a better
professional reputation than some of
these bottom-feeding youtubers to get to
the bottom and I've had to clarify over
and over again that I never Doc's
anybody so it's a big deal that you can
just backtrack now and say okay that
part was light but what's more
interesting is how you responded notify
I want to drive home is I have never
ducks a person in my entire life and I
have said that and I'm standing by that
and I'm happy that you concede at that
point and I'll say this I apologize for
using the word splash page you were
correct you are 100% correct about that
but I googled that after I say that and
I literally showed in the email where
someone told me that a year ago I
literally was repeating what was told to
me but I'm never an intention did I
question about that then why did you
wait until the Rubin report weeks after
all of this to say that you made a
mistake saying whoa splash okay because
after I said it you kit come on the
Internet
after you say something you guys are
already jumped on everyone was saying
liar liar liar splash splash baby's the
only way that I could have actually
clarified that with some integrity was
to forward the email since I said oh
here's a screenshot of the email they
would have said it was doctored the
conspiracies were getting crazier and
crazier and crazier and I understand
that you know you didn't when you're on
my show you didn't realize when you said
the splash you hadn't even realized that
write it no no I had no idea
tweeted after because I still thought I
perceived it to be true
it was told me by a web developer I went
to school for web design and I think
that he was referring to was a splash of
the technologies okay but like it was
something that went wrong and how can
you blame people for thinking it was
alive when you wait week I didn't blame
another if I didn't blame them
I'd say you can't I answered your
question I didn't blame them I said it
wasn't a lie and I weighed to clear
clarify it I answered your time so you
understand how people can perceive that
I was alive yes yes okay okay okay
that's right I understand
a lot of this stuff is semantics I
genuinely thought that I fought the
totally different word meant something
else cuz it's what was told to me and he
saw the emails so when I'm getting
called
being triple attacted it's a dog it's a
pile on the only way that I can come the
truth is on my own terms and I'm gonna
show him the emails that I never liked
but did you really think like when you
said when you as you said the weather
Laura said at first but you repeated it
saying it was a non-functioning splash
page do you really think the whole
website was on functioning why not I 110
percent there's just like it's like one
email we built something okay there's
probably a hundred emails he was like
phase one splash page people will be
able to like you know include some
things whatever whatever we having built
technology where you could actually pull
it from Facebook it's what we were
trying to build was for Facebook to be
able to talk the social autopsy so
nobody had to tell the names we could
just verify that the secrets are owned
by okay yeah it was an archive so when
he said it was a splash you know it's a
splash we haven't built it on the money
to build the entire thing out I thought
that was true I held that as a truth in
my head for a full year for 18 months
it's not like this was like new and I
was like Oh what does this mean he
emailed that to me in February of 2016
so I just thought it was true I never I
never questioned it because he's a web
developer would you question the one
developer if they said this is what
we're doing like I I personally would
have probably known there's someone
called it a non-functioning so great for
you you're conceding a little naivete
perhaps on your part or just not
understanding phrases your value would
understand little bits off about the
direct topic I don't want to address a
like an has told me about me about maybe
two or three days ago on Twitter you
said that I made an autistic girl cry on
YouTube that I was in the lab she and me
don't historic right
that girl has come out and said there's
not a stick right so I love this because
how does it feel when people take
hearsay and perpetuated as the truth you
were so angry that I did that I
literally did this as an experiment I
knew you're gonna bring it up okay
you were so you were so nice I know I
was told to I don't know I was told she
was autistic by its threat who a bunch
of youtubers have a strong dislike for
you and your little gang of youtubers
that take people up like that's what you
guys do you you talk about people you
get it in the superhero that you're
saying it here in the same group of
people so if this is what was being told
to me I'm not gonna call anybody yeah
look I'm not gonna I'll fall on the
sword or whatever it was when URI see it
was told to me OK by about 7 youtubers
and it is a pretty terrible what the
person is autistic she's out with
depression and anxiety at the same
people that did all these videos on me
that
pylon for a girl a girl that was
depressing anxious okay you say I don't
want talk about this is all topic it's
nothing to why I'm here today know who'd
be like me could be completely a girl
that was off off her rocker and did
whatever I'm not even gonna speculate
but the point is if you don't like when
people do that to you and don't
understand all the facts don't do it to
them okay you too can do a difference
yeah I don't wanna do any question
doesn't matter but but you truthfully
you guys can do a different live stream
where you can hash out all the all the I
said this you said this this was a lie
this was a confused statement blah blah
blah you try to resolve to respond to
lies said about her suppose you're for
that's a right here for you don't get to
hijack it was her let her respond to
that and then and then I'm gonna try to
bring this thing I was corresponding
part of the entire back and forth that
you and I have which is part of the
reason why we're here because you and I
had back and forth on the internet was
involving you attacking my character
saying and meet an autistic girl cry
this girl came out and said but she was
absolutely upset that you use that
against her you spread a rumor and did
she say that go on Twitter okay she
personally inbox me and told me that you
were one of the worst people that she's
ever be the chaos so don't don't do dog
you made her cry talking with a few
major crop also tweeted okay she also
tweeted so don't don't use her don't use
right now that's messed up gone through
it don't use her as your as your pawn
you already made her cry don't use her
as a pawn Candace don't use ratchet on
dick this is a sidebar hold on you but
you both can however you want to deal
with this portion of the conversation
you guys could both we're not ending it
on that we're gonna what we're gonna try
to end this on is that I think I have to
all right I have to you you you all
right you can respond to that
just let her respond no I don't like
this because what you did is you made a
girl crying to live stream with a bunch
of likes you can't buy the youtuber by
nine years anyway there's bad girls
because what I'm gonna tell you I'm
happy to do is saying what the girl said
to me and I'm not comfortable doing it
so we need to move on Tyler st. John I
got to bed myself panic camper in myself
damn she cannot tell me what happened
and what I did without me being out to
respond and you're gonna let me it's a
video you're gonna let me keep up and
watch what you did they absolutely can I
went oh clarify exactly what the
situation was in June at VidCon there
was someone who came into my private
hotel room illegally tapped me and my
friends in the private hotel room we had
a really hard time getting her after
that happened I did a livestream with my
friends who were in that hotel rooms
girl Kent defenders in that hotel room
and we didn't mention her name at all we
were keeping a completely anonymous
person saying well as friends talk about
that's crazy can happen to us in a hotel
in VidCon someone came in and illegally
tapped us and wouldn't leave so this
person then because she watches us began
tweeting to let her on and say her piece
she came on the livestream it was an
ugly moment there was an argument we
talked about how you know everything
that she did she was deny everything was
ugly moment I private the video what
happened was discuss what happened why
did I say what happened was it's all so
disgusting she legally to have someone
to thank anyways so what happened was
about two or three days ago Candice
began tweeting that um basically a
complete character attack saying look
basically look hugging we debating this
person being autistic girl cry she
pulled that out of thin air maybe goat
always well they can't defend myself
this is this is this is behind right now
can't wait I hear you the audience
cannot stand cannot stand him whatsoever
she's not autistic and even if she was
autistic she used that as a as escaping
or double attacking said you attacked
her in the video and made her cry
myself now don't use a girl that you
made cry gbk Lupin right now that's what
you guys did was low hand and disgusting
she probably will discuss ahead she
probably the video because it's the
fastest moments lieutenant this is and
you guys who you guys okay
you are she hates you you can actually
absolutely hate you which make sure
nothing to me and she retweeted logics
buddy on you she hates you as welcome
guys guys I'm asking you both as as if
you've got a little bit of respect for
me we got it we will end this because I
think we're just veering into the wrong
way but I think what I think if we can
get this to anything that anyone's gonna
feel right about I think I think
basically you have said your piece there
will be a certain amount of people that
are going to accept either what your
your word is or not that is what it is I
think you have acknowledged a couple
points that clarify this it's and I
don't think that discounts any of your
other feelings all the other fighting
trolling stuff like yeah this is this is
the Internet has leaked into real life
that basically is what this is calling
it fighting and trolling when it's
someone else why don't you let him talk
thank you sir you haven't let anyone
talking this whole time like I'm the
only one interrupting people we're all
doing it we're all doing it I think the
point of doing this thing had very
little to do with all of the the little
fighting and who blocked who and all of
that stuff right the point of this was
what did Candice create what what were
the intentions and what came of it and
it I I can tell you this I think I have
a sense of what the truth is on that
that is my feeling the other stuff
related to this I think the stuff maybe
Blair that you're responding to a little
bit more is just where I can't spend my
life in that part of this you know say
it was and I think that's completely
fair I think that's completely fair we
all have to defend ourselves in
different ways
so look I don't know that we can get
anywhere further with this right now so
we can either do the QA there's a bunch
of questions that people want to do if
we can if we can do it kind of
respectfully and and clearly and cleanly
or we can just let it be and but more
than anything else I really hope that
the two you realized that you guys for
all the raw feelings right now
you guys probably agree on 90% of stuff
like III look that that may be true in
terms I don't honestly you have don't
know what your political beliefs are but
in terms of how this was dealt with and
how it could have been dealt with I
genuinely don't have respect for the
situation whatsoever and I hope I don't
think that you know we're gonna probably
be in the same social circles which is
fine with you and fine with me it's now
it's what I want for my career and I
consider this this will definitely be a
low light it was definitely yes so every
disappointed as well in the way it was
handled I'm disappointed in the way
about you attempted to you
damage control all of this involving
telling lies about people and that was
my intention to come in here and say
what about the slide with a sign that
was the point
clearly I conceded that your website
while you never got around to actually
adopting someone even though that was
the intent of the website to spread
people's names attached to their
employers and their schools you directly
didn't end up having the right you
directly didn't end up having the
capacity to actually do that because you
didn't actually launch the website
however the information was accessible
by people who did dock those people and
all of those people maybe not all but I
saw about six or seven people whose
personal addresses workplaces and
telephone numbers were docked so my
phone so my attempt might somewhat yeah
so my entire contention with this was
that she created a resource for doctors
well this a little bit reminds me of
sort of the road to hell is paved with
good intentions I believe your
intentions here I don't attack people's
intentions until I see it wrong I
believe your intentions were good I
believe the intentions that you started
this thing with we're good and you
realize that it was wrong you are
acknowledging that whether what people
do after that on the Internet is sort of
hard for any of us to yeah it's crazy
that I have to be like responsible for
what somebody who is really for anybody
Doc's anybody you have to be a
okay human being all right so first up
I'll throw it to you guys here do you
want to do the QA if we can do it in in
a kind of calm way I'm really okay
either way if you just feel like we've
we've gotten to where we need to be
we've gotten to where we're getting to
know I'm not for Q&A
I can't a sponsor you know I can do
committee I mean I'm down I'm sorry I
don't think for the sake of disagreeing
but I really okay okay you know
off-brand for me to even be like across
from someone or you know what there's
usually I wanted to clarify that didn't
make a daxing website and I was think
you can't do this without me okay all
right look you know what at the end at
the end of the day everyone watching at
the end of the day everyone watch it
look I feel like I although this has
been sort of nutty I feel like I
actually whatever questions I had
remaining in my mind I do feel like have
been answered for me I hope that some
other people will feel that too but
let's do this
we're gonna do a 20 minute Q&A we're
gonna do it because because people have
been in this thing asking I don't want
to be this disrespectful in our time
all right guys give us literally 60
seconds just to refill some waters and
we're gonna take a breath and all right
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys we're back
we took a breath we refilled Blair's
water we're gonna try to tone it down
just for the Q&A we everything being
equal as I said I feel like I got what I
needed I know we're getting lost in a
little bit of this stuff and you guys
can all continue to make videos or not
make videos and Candice can respond or
not Blair can never talk about this
again or she can everyone can live their
life the way we want that's the beauty
of freedom okay so we're gonna do a
couple questions here for the first
fewer were comments actually on super
chat as a web developer I have created
front ends that allowed for rudimentary
data collection such as name and address
to build out all the layers in the and
test the underlying code that is a far
cry from a fully functional website so I
think that's something that Candice has
consistently been saying someone on
supers chat said take control Davey boy
it's a little late for that okay
somewhat at super Chad said tune in drop
out saying I would never tell a client
that such a site had a data base because
it gives them the impression that is
fully functional when it isn't I would
have called my demo version splash pages
too okay so this I'm just going through
these in the order that they are I did
not pick this order here so it's a
really great content thanks for
exploring the misunderstanding red pill
black was innocent the entire time but
Blair White made some fair points even
if the criticism was moot still event
fan of both you okay and I think you
guys are actually going to have a load
of crossover in fans which is the funny
part here Dave looks so happy to finally
have a live debate on his show again all
right I'll take it first well this is
the first that went to this level let's
say I've had some conversations that we
did more debates about garden thing
things like that
Rubick please tell both girls to stop
shouting interrupting and trying to
one-up each other breathe slow down and
be patient you want to take a breath a
little late I will say okay Jenna
screams I will say that it was dumb yeah
I listen I will gladly if you guys will
ever do it have you both over for dinner
at some other appointment is all you
know behind us and we can talk it we can
talk the rest of it out over some booze
somebody said the reason why people
piled on red pill black recently is do a
lot due to algorithms not a conspiracy
so that's interested discuss that a
little bit before that it's hard to know
how much of this is
are these people all coordinating also
say fair like I am new to YouTube like I
think people don't understand that like
I don't understand what what you might
perceive to be so normal how long have
you been on YouTube about a year and
some months yeah so free but you might
perceive to be so normal because you're
a more experienced youtuber or like I've
only been on YouTube for two three
months like it just seemed like crazy to
me that 11 youtubers would jump into a
search ad that might be totally normal
it could be my own ignorance but it just
seems very aggressive yeah it's a real
thing I think it's more of a case of
like this was just something that was a
hot topic at the time yeah okay wait
someone here did ask a good question
that I think a few people that we didn't
address that I think bunch of people
have said so he's saying that people
were mad the sight was never taken down
so why wasn't the splash I meant to ask
you this actually why wasn't the splash
page taken down until what about ten
days ago because I wanted to be really
honest people about my background where
I came from I never thought like to
delete my past I always talked about it
I was very forward with it this is
something that came up they didn't find
this like I said they didn't break the
story I'd been talking about it in every
single interview and as I said it we
didn't build a technology out and I'm
happy those web developers are saying
that they would call it a splash page
because that's what it was called we
didn't build a technology so I didn't I
thought no harm no foul it's not
functioning leave it there and it was
gonna naturally expire in February which
it is okay a few people said this which
is one of Blair's main points if you had
just taken down the site which you're
addressing now nobody would have cared
but the doubling down and calling people
like tria logic quote funded made
everything worse so that's a point
Blair's met a couple times okay I want
someone to look at me the way Dave
Rubens looking at his assortment of
whisky right now it's all right there
there's a lot of good stuff that would I
could have just actually stepped off
camera and started drinking okay Candice
your site is well intentioned as it is
but as tremendous potential of abuse
you're acknowledging that yeah why do
you trust yourself or anyone else for
that matter with that kind of power by
the way I don't like I said I've said a
thousand times totally naive stepped
into an internet culture that I want
nothing to do with and had nothing to do
with politics
it just was meant to be something I've
said often it was something that was
intend that was for good and it would
have very quickly been used for evil
yeah all right here's one that a couple
people have also addressed sort of and I
think Blair kind of hid this Candace why
are you calling
tubers with more subs than you bottom
feeders and basement dwellers it was not
jealousy it was a critique uh listen if
you think a critique to me is doing one
video that's interactive when you do
five videos and you're talking about
somebody's looks okay and you're talked
about everything they every layer of me
like the videos that I do they don't
even like my content all this stuff if
it was just a critique fine
they went into full insult and to me
that's a bottom-feeding tactic that's
very high school it's very juvenile they
stuck to the facts would have had much
more respect but they didn't okay and II
wore ski made cogent arguments about
what the problem was and you have yet to
address them lots of people just want an
apology personally I want to forgive you
have over your adversarial stance makes
that difficult so you did sort of say
that you don't want to apologize because
your intentions were not even that it's
just that as we've already said I didn't
build something that could be docked
that could Docs people and I was going
to finish my statement before if those
people got ducks of course like in if
their lives I don't think they works
it's been a year we would have heard
about it if their lives were ruined
because their address was put on the
Deep Web of Kiwi farms of course I'm
sorry that happened
as a result of something that I was
building and was never launched because
some for some reason people were able to
access it on the back end like of course
I'm sorry but I was being asked to
apologize for Docs people and I never
did it so of course I'm gonna double
down and say no I'm not apologizing
because I didn't do that no can I just
say the like QE Farms is objectively not
considered a well okay so I think this
may be a little bit of a one of the
definition things so I did see if you I
don't know I actually don't know but I
did see a few comments that a bunch of
people are saying Kiwi farms it's not
Deep Web because it's publicly
accessible so I didn't so I was like you
have to use some sort of program to hide
your IP and unlike go really deep that's
yeah I didn't no no okay pretend I know
things okay that's that's where the
proper right so the problem is gathering
information in one place organisation of
this data make it a more pointed tool
for a bad actor to use so this is
absolutely what your point was it's not
okay to say it's completely your fault
but you can say putting the information
under one roof is not as the same as
getting it off on Facebook so that
that's an interesting distinction they
could have done this on face weight was
recognized yeah like this is this is the
information they're gonna go there for
I totally understand that as I said it
never launched and I don't know how many
times I can say that it hasn't launched
I get this argument of if if if but I
don't live in a world of ifs I didn't I
didn't launch it I dropped the project I
realized it could be used for evil okay
you know like Lacey's I think they're
talking about Laci green like Lacey who
was skeptical at first but seems okay
and others who quote change sides I'll
give them the benefit of the doubt and
let them prove they've changed the
dangers of the project were that big
I'm not totally sure I followed all that
Blair are you going to do another chat
with Theron soon maybe about free speech
and of either of you seen Ferguson the
play I haven't and I should do you know
there she was there and she's gone
alright let's see oh it's not it's teryn
right okay it's Darren yeah okay
alright you know there's a couple other
things here but I think Aaron Meyer
reached out to me sent me an email
yeah actually yeah alright listen I
don't know that that we got exactly what
we wanted to get out of this but I don't
know that that's actually possible and
these when the way these things go so
you both have ally in me and none of us
are perfect and I hope we got somewhere
with this thing so I hope that you guys
feel like we got somewhere with this
thing what are the chances the internet
just stops with this right now that's
how the internet fades right um yeah
things blow over and then that was my
whole thing it was like I didn't
understand why it was like drawn-out if
like all this was so easily cleared up
why she couldn't have made I mean
honestly if it was me and again I'm not
you but if it was me and there was all
these lies about me a rumors about me
the first thing I would have done it's
made a video on my channel and said this
isn't sure this isn't sure this isn't
you but instead you walked or everyone
asking questions you blocked all
criticism and you drew it out until this
day on the Rubin report which honestly I
know it probably seems like Oh we'll get
you know it'll be heard more because the
Rubin report but in reality people who
are wonder about this will go directly
to your channel so I don't know that
would just be my time not in time be
condescending that would be my advice if
anything ever happens like this you
should probably just run your channel
right I genuinely did not think that
this was going to be this plan of a
portion especially for something that
never launched a and B I did not feel
that I don't like that you keep saying
that you should have respond to the
questions the videos were already made
that's a huge insult to go out and make
the
about some before you contact them I
didn't cut you off please don't cut me
off okay to make videos about someone
without context and I just think it's
wrong and I am NOT going to as I said
the expression negotiate with terrorists
and say this is what you have to do now
to make amends because we made a bunch
of videos about you I didn't like it I
thought it was nasty and I dealt with it
as I dealt with it you know it's
interesting it's interesting to me as
well as three of us do put videos up on
YouTube for whatever whatever we
consider ourselves you also do learn
about this in different ways a year ago
if people have been attacking me the way
they attack me now I might have fought
more I now if you see it as an exercise
in futility which I think sort of where
you're at and perhaps yours your style
would be to be attack them back more and
that's plenty of people do that and just
approaches different Salah I just think
it would have been a lot more that's for
adaptive that's alright well I hope you
guys got something out of this and you
know the conversation obviously is gonna
continue I'm gonna try to convince them
both to have a drink with me right now
and we drink right now see how that goes
but you both didn't exactly say know it
with those looks drinking all right
thanks guys
yeah
[Music]
you